[Music]
we want to bring in now the director of
jihad watch Robert Spencer who is I
believe on the line Robert you
there yes I am um so you saw the press
release from the White House we hear you
fine thank you you saw the press release
I believe from the White House this
morning saying they're going to convene
um a symposium essentially on violent
extremism the word Islam the word Muslim
never mentioned um
is well it's just another absurd sign
really it's a sign that the
Administration has no willingness to
deal with this situation as it really is
there is no possible way that they can
defeat this threat if they are not even
willing to name it and it's this is
something it's not anything new but I'm
absolutely certain that this Symposium
as it's been announced since it won't
name the problem itself in its very uh
convening is not going to make a bit of
difference in dealing with this problem
adequately we wanted to talk to you
about these noo zones in Paris and you
heard our own Greg pelot who lived there
for eight years saying he would the
police wouldn't go there as he was
driving with police cars make a left
here no no no we can't go into those
no-go zones these these areas ruled by
Sharia law where the police won't even
go learning now that in the United
States we even have similar zones in
Upstate New York and Texas and other
spots uh where Sharia law in place um
does this mean a big clamp down is
coming on these noo zones or will they
continue to operate
unfettered well they've been operating
for years and uh the problem is in
France of course there's so many of them
there's 751 according to an official
French government website and so it's
not going to be very easy for the French
to suddenly say we're going to start
enforcing French law in these areas but
this is something that has to be done
and the longer they postpone the problem
the more difficult it will be for them
to deal with it in the United States the
situation is very different
there are growing Sharia enclaves in
urban areas like Dearborn Michigan and
Northern New Jersey but there's probably
even a bigger potential problem in these
uh areas that you mention in rural areas
where there are camps of the Muslims of
the Americas which is affiliated with
jamat Al fukra which is a group in
Pakistan Daniel Pearl was on his way to
interview its head when he was uh
murdered and uh they have been
responsible for murders in the United
States including that of Rashad Khalifa
who was a uh Muslim scholar who was
considered heretical in Arizona he was
murdered by members of Muslims of the
Americas in 1992 that've been linked to
10 other murders as well as firebombings
and so on and there are indications uh
evidence actually strong evidence that
there's Guerilla arms training going on
in these camps in these rural areas and
of course that's unmistakably to prepare
for Jihad in the United States Robert
Spencer of jihad watch thanks for the
perspective on that we appreciate it
thank you thanks Robert